one of the things that is funny about
this clip which was Rachel Maddow
talking to Lawrence O'Donnell on MSNBC
kind of just skylarking or you know
floating a trial balloon of a way where
hey maybe we can get around this with
Spiro Agnew you get a 40 pound 40 count
Federal indictment that is brought
against him not related to Watergate but
because of crimes that he was committing
in his own office in the White House
and in that case with the justice
department
bravely and and nimbly and
controversially brokered with him is
that that indictment would essentially
go poof in exchange for him agreeing to
get out of the White House and so that
that delicate balance between needing a
political solution to the criminal in
the White House and needing a criminal
solution and criminal law solution to
the criminal in the White House is one
that 50 years ago this year in 1973 we
dealt with uh in 1972 we dealt with with
Spiro Agnew you have to wonder if the
justice department is considering
whether there is some political solution
to this criminal problem whether part of
the issue here is not just that Trump
has committed crimes but that Trump has
committed crimes and plans on being back
in the White House do they consider as
part of a potential plea offer something
that would prescribe him proscribe him
from from running for office again I
don't know I would imagine if anything
like that happened that it would have to
come from the defense side of the
negotiation that the that the Trump team
would would say oh by the way way and
with this we will also you know drop out
of the uh the race for president
otherwise it would put the justice
department in this position that Donald
Trump claims they're in you know he
claims they're trying to stop him simply
trying to stop him from becoming
president again and that's the only
reason uh they're doing this we're
entering a Banana Republic phase where
you know each successive president can
threaten you know their their
predecessor with you know being put in
jail or having all kinds of conditions
put on their continued citizenship and
whatnot
um you have now you know people on MSNBC
particularly people like Rachel Maddow
were saying you know the problem with
Trump is that he is the destroyer of
norms he's going you know he he you know
has his steak cooked well and he eats it
with ketchup he's like a horrible human
being he's an oath in ogre a bull in a
china shop et cetera but there you have
people like that actually floating an
idea where if you read about about this
in Chile after Pinochet you would be
like what the is going on here this
is the you know the quintessence of like
a Banana Republic and it's being talked
about seriously on you know major media
yeah I uh the problem is I see it is
that uh to go back to something we
discussed before excuse me we um we just
we haven't had a conversation we haven't
had an explicit conversation about the
nature of the free pass that that
high-ranking politicians are going to
get they're definitely going to get some
kind of a free pass we haven't really
had a candid discussion about you know
sort of sort of what it looks like lies
know that they get lost
and so that leaves a room for somebody
like Trump to say well wait a minute you
know Hillary Clinton is you know a
corrupt criminal flaunter of norms um
who put you know National Security at
significant Risk by you know setting up
this Betty Crocker server in her house
like what why am I getting prosecuted
that's not a completely unreasonable
position to take now part of what I
think would come up if we had this very
you know sort of unseemly discussion
about you know why high-ranking
politicians get a free pass that the
rest of us don't and what the shape of
that pass is
um is for example Hillary I don't think
Hillary Clinton is any less corrupt than
Donald Trump is she might even be more
corrupt but I think she's less dangerous
I think she's less irresponsible I think
she sort of understands institutional
norms and the importance of things like
um you know uh
cozying up not cozying up to dictators
like uh Kim Jong-un so so in some sense
you could make a case that she should
get a bigger and more durable free pass
than Donald Trump
um and and you wouldn't be crazy but
like can you imagine I can't imagine
ever having that discussion explicitly
and so this heuristic you know this this
um formula is just out there somewhere
in The Ether we've never really tried to
work it through or or
concretize it and yet it's there and the
the sort of seeming inexplicability of
why Hillary Clinton gets a free pass but
Donald Trump doesn't get a free pass is
going to be a source of conflict and
grievance because we can't have an
honest discussion about who gets free
passes and why
are there any you know structural or
institutional reforms that would help
with this problem I mean we had your
call your Cato colleague Ian Vasquez on
here a while ago talking about the
decline in human Freedom around the
world uh particularly post pandemic and
a lot of that has to do with
institutional Decline and Rise in
corruption uh specifically here in the
United States is there anything there
that could help
stop this slide towards the Banana
Republic if that's how we're putting it
or is this really ultimately a political
problem
so the answer can it be saved because
you know it can we redeem the
institutions I don't know but yes there
is something that can be done and Nick
kind of alluded to it earlier
put a a fire in the belly libertarian
in charge of the Department of Justice
and give them you know in effect a free
uh you know give them full authority to
enforce all the laws against whoever
breaks them
um and uh you will see a a rapid change
in behavior
um because you know if I for example uh
were that attorney general um I would
create a whole new unit within the
Department of Justice to make sure that
we have completely revoked the free
passes uh that high-ranking politicians
currently uh enjoy and make sure that
they understand that those free passes
have been revoked um and that they
themselves will receive at least as much
attention from the Department of Justice
as for example uh inner city uh drug
dealers have been receiving
um and you know for however long I don't
know how long it would be before that
attorney general will be impeached
probably a matter of uh weeks instead of
months but uh I think we're talking
minutes but yeah hopefully hopefully
they get weeks yeah but you know I I
sort of fantasize about the maybe you
know bringing a um a Jason Voorhees
hockey mask into the office on the first
day of the the job the way that you know
Elon Musk brought a whatever it was a
toilet just to convey to the kitchen
sink kitchen right yeah it must be later
used as a toilet I'm sure so so you know
I'm being a little bit flippant but I do
think that if if it were possible uh to
to have uh you know the the the Attorney
General of the United States not be a
member of either tribe neither team blue
nor team red uh but somebody who is not
does not have that political affiliation
and has a commitment uh to even-handedly
enforcing the law not just you know sort
of saying that which they all understand
they're supposed to say it but actually
doing it
um and revoking the kinds of free passes
that we saw handed out to uh Hillary
Clinton
um and um uh arguably Mike Pence and at
least so far Hunter Biden and just
saying look I don't care I don't care
who what what office you hold or who
you're related to
um you're going to be held to the same
standard as the rest as the as all the
Muggles out there
um you know I think that would be
progress it might burn the whole thing
down but at least it would I think sort
of Lance the boil of this you know this
this
um cynicism this this uh you know anger
and frustration that people have that
it's only people on my team who are
getting singled out for bad trip and not
people on the other team that's not true
but but you're not crazy if you have
that impression that was an excerpt from
our live stream talking about the Trump
indictment with the Cato institute's
Clark Neely if you want to see the full
conversation go here
and if you want to see a different
excerpt go here and make sure to join us
every Thursday at 1 pm Eastern when
reason Zach weismuller and I talk with
somebody very interesting telling you
something that you need to know